6 feuilles d'arbres emporté par le vin
une pour chacune des vies fauchées par
le tireur de la grande mosquée et ce
mémorial est une façon d'exprimer
publiquement que la haine ne gagne
jamais le maire la bombe rêve d'une vie
meilleure et d'une plus grande ouverture
envers l'autre à québec
un espoir partagé par le cofondateur du
centre culturel islamique qui interpelle
les enfants des disparus
tout le monde ou âmes et tout le monde
souhaite que vous soyez
les grandes citoyenne et le grand
citoyen de demain pour encore on aurait
cette ville et honorer la mémoire de vos
parents c'est très très très émouvant et
toute la symbolique qui entoure en fait
le monument amir belkacemi a perdu son
père dans la tuerie de la grande mosquée
il salue la volonté de la ville de
québec de vouloir rassembler ses
citoyens on voit déjà fait avec ce geste
que que c'est que cette façon de passer
le fait beaucoup de chemin et ça fait du
bien ça nous unit ont fait en quelque
sorte comme symbole c'est un symbole
unificateur le chemin du vivre ensemble
demeurent cependant tortueux en début de
semaine statistique canada révélait que
70 crimes haineux avaient été rapportés
l'an dernier à québec
une statistique qui place la capitale au
quatrième rang des villes au pays pour
le nombre d'incidents par tranche de 100
mille habitants
cette haine l'a évidemment la façon la
plus facile et la plus large et
d'exprimer régis labeaume rappelle
l'importance de dénoncer l'intolérance
et d'agir pour faire évoluer les
mentalités
son administration a autorisé la
création d'un premier cimetière musulman
une consultante a été embauché pour
tisser des liens avec les communautés
culturelles
n'empêche le défi ne sera pas facile à
relever
parce qu'ils aimaient qu'il ya un fond
de haine qui est entretenue il ya des
gens qui vont chercher ce que puis
mauvais dans l'estomac d'un humain un
bien acquis font de l'argent avec ça tu
assez simple vous le savez savez ce que
je veux dire
le maire n'en démord pas les
propriétaires de certaines radios
privées de la capitale aurait un examen
de conscience à faire ici olivier
lemieux radio canada québec